-Another thing
that seems to, uh...
seems to be splitting
the way Democrats think,
not just
the idea of electability
but also the idea
of impeachment --
is this a fool's errand?
I think you have many
in the party who think
this is a man who's done
plenty of things
that are why we have
impeachment as an option
and others who are saying,
"No, we need to focus on the
ballot box as a way of removal."
What do you think?
-I think this is another one
of those things where Democrats
are sort of
outthinking themselves,
like in the same way
with the electability thing.
Like, you may really want
to beat Donald Trump.
You can't personally work out
who's the most electable
candidate to win the primary.
In the same way, impeachment --
you sort of
can't really game out
what the political impact
of impeachment is going to be.
That's not the kind of process
impeachment is.
If a president commits crimes,
commits high crimes
and misdemeanors,
the way the Congress is supposed
to hold him accountable
is by opening
an impeachment inquiry,
doing an investigation,
and then voting
on whether or not they think
that it rises to that level.
Whether or not that hurts the
President, helps the President,
hurts the Democrats,
helps the Democrats,
A, is unknowable,
and, B,
should be beside the point.
And if you're doing it
for the right reasons,
I think you are more likely
to persuade the country
that you've done it
for the right reasons
rather than you having tried to
think everybody around a corner,
in terms of how
this is supposed to work out.
I just think just be --
Approach these things simply.
Pick the best candidate
who you think would make
the best president.
Approach impeachment
in terms of the Constitutional
imperative here.
Who cares who it's good for?
-It does strike me, as well,
whether he is impeached or not,
he'll act like he was impeached.
-Yes.
Yes, yes.
-And, you know, he's gonna --
he's not gonna --
if he doesn't get impeached,
say, "You know what?
That was a real fair shake
I got from the Democrats.
I tip my hat."
-Yeah, exactly!
-"I may have been wrong
about those bozos."
-It's true.
They're gonna run campaign ads.
He's gonna give speeches
talking about them
being socialists
who want to impeach him.
There's nothing you can do
to make him
not call you a socialist.
-Right.
-Just do what you think
is right.
He's gonna call you names.
If you're really lucky, he'll
give you a diminutive Nickname.
-Yeah.
-Congratulations.
-Yeah, that'd be a winner.
-There's no way that you can
get around that stuff.
And he will --
And the Republicans
will all campaign
as if the Democrats
are just "impeachment-mad
socialists,"
so just
do what you think is right.
Don't worry about
what people say about you.
-We both talked about
Trump's adventures in Europe,
and that was just --
in general, I just found a peace
with him being there
just because it shifted by five
hours when things could happen.
[ Laughter ]
You know, at like 9:00,
if I was at dinner,
I had a thought of, like,
"If I haven't
heard anything now,
he's probably asleep,"
you know?
[ Laughter ]
But you --
-You were so good, though.
When you described him as, like,
every American tourist thing
that anybody has ever done wrong
anywhere in the world,
he's doing them all at once.
-Yeah.
-Like,
that's exactly what he was.
When you described him that way,
I was like,
"That's what he's doing!"
He's embodying all of
the worst stereotypes
that everybody in the world
has about dumb Americans,
and he's living them large!
[ Laughter ]
Like, with their leaders.
It was just...
-Yeah. Well, you can tell
they look at him,
and they're not saying,
"Oh, I've met a guy
like this before."
They're like, "I've met
a guy like this before,
but it was 100 different guys."
-Yes.
[ Laughter ]
-Like, this --
He's like a Voltron
of all of it.
-Yeah.
-You had a wonderful --
I had not seen this photo
that you called out
on your show last night,
which is,
here's the Trump family
in a picture.
And I will say, they all look
lovely, beautiful gowns.
-The Trump adult children.
-Trump adult children.
-Why are they there?
They don't work
for the government.
-Who pointed this out to you?
Did you find this on your own?
-So, I was reading
the Irish press because,
as you talked about
on your show, as well,
Trump goes over to Ireland
and is like,
"Yeah, about your border wall
with Northern Ireland..."
It's like,
"Dude, there's no border wall
with Northern Ireland."
And that's
a really sensitive subject!
please don't go there.
Ugh!
So, I was looking at
the Irish press
to see how they covered
that disaster by the President,
and what I found
was they were like,
"Hey, look at this picture
of the Trump adult children.
Isn't that lovely, how they're
posing for that photo?"
-That's great but we're gonna
zoom in on something over here.
Right there.
"No photos."
-"No photographs."
[ Laughter ]
-They literally --
They literally are like,
"Let's take a picture,"
and they're like,
"Well, not over there, 'cause
it says 'no photographs.'"
And they're like,
"No, let's do it there."
Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
-The President's whole family
poses in front of
the "No Photos" picture.
Yep, that's pretty much
our lives now.
-That's their style.
That is their style.
[ Laughter ]
-Yeah.
-I want to be serious
here for a second,
because you've done
a really good job of covering
a very scary situation right now
with all the abortion laws
that are being passed
at the state level.
-Yeah.
-And, obviously, there was
a lot of talk
about what Alabama did,
but there's also a lot happening
in Missouri right now
where there are basically
efforts being made
to close the last
abortion provider in the state.
-Yeah.
-Can you talk a little bit
about, like, what actually
is happening there
and how punitive it is,
these laws
that they're talking about?
-The thing that's different
about what's happening
in Missouri right now
is that they are the closest
any state has ever been
to completely ending
legal abortion access
in the entire state.
No state has been able
to do that since Roe vs. Wade
was passed
by the Supreme Court in 1973.
But for the first time,
Missouri's state government,
the Republican-controlled
state government,
is trying to shut down the last
abortion provider in the state.
So they're trying to take
the last clinic's license away.
And as they are doing that, the
state government has come in,
and they have told the doctors
at that clinic
that while they're still open
and while women are still able
to get abortions there,
the doctors at that clinic
must now start giving medically
unnecessary pelvic examinations,
like vaginal examinations,
to women, specifically --
basically, as the cost of them
asking for an abortion.
So, it's medically unnecessary.
The doctors don't want to do it.
There's no reason to do it.
The women who are getting
abortions do not want this done,
and the state government
has come in and mandated
that they get this extra
internal exam
while they're trying
to shut down that last clinic.
And so, we've been reporting
on that for the past week or so.
The state government in Missouri
got very mad at us
about reporting on it,
but it's freaking true.
And we went to the clinic
and talked to the staff there
about how they are being forced
to do this to their patients now
on orders of the state.
And it's just --
I think it's upsetting, I think,
to a lot of people,
both the state of abortion
rights around the country
and what's going on in Missouri,
but the fact that they're
doing that to these women
on order
of that state government
is just sort of
horror-movie disturbing.
-Well, we certainly appreciate
you guys actually getting
on the ground there
and going and talking
to those people 'cause that
is incredibly informative
and necessary
at times like these.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Last thing I want to ask.
-Yeah.
-You are, in the middle
of all this --
moderating debates,
hosting your own show --
you are writing a book, as well.
Just to like relax and unplug,
you're writing a book.
Is it a fun --
It's a fun romantic-comedy romp?
Is that a safe way
to describe it?
-Yeah, it's a romantic
little ditty
about the geopolitics
of the oil and gas industry.
[ Laughter ]
-Rachel!
Rachel, no!
-No, I do that.
You know, I do some vaping.
It's, like, pretty much, like,
It's my kicking downtime.
-"Blowout."
It's called "Blowout."
-It's called "Blowout."
It comes out October 1st.
Yeah, I'll come back
and talk to you about it.
-Okay, great.
I look forward to it.
It's always great to see you.
That's Rachel Maddow, everybody.